[Musique]
octobre 1939 la victoire de l'Allemagne
nazie sur la Pologne et branle le monde
dans Berlin pavoisier la Wehrmacht
victorieuse défile devant le chef du
Troisième Reich Adolf Hitler
fantassin cavalier aviateur par
rachutiste tankistes et marins ont
offert une victoire rapide et facile à
leur fureur
mais l'esprit de celui-ci est déjà
occupé par une nouvelle conquête celle
de la France
[Musique]
grouper derrière lui généraux amiraux et
dignitaire du parti entendent monter
vers la tribune les acclamations de la
foule pourtant nombre d'entre eux
militaires de carrière estime que
l'avait remarque n'est pas prête pour
affronter un tel conflit
l'ancien caporal de la Grande Guerre de
leur démontrer que son armée c'est
soldats sont cependant capable de
vaincre
[Musique]
dans les casernes allemandes les soldats
de toutes armes s'entraînent répète sans
cesse le maniement des armes les plus
diverses
la Wehrmacht est malgré tout considérée
comme une armée conventionnelle
dépendante encore trop des transports
immobiles et dont beaucoup de matériels
sont dépassés si les parachutistes
forment des unités modernes et encore
peu connues les Panzer comme le Mark III
sont souvent inférieures au char
français et britanniques le bombardier
en piquait chtuka est une proie facile
pour les chasseurs ennemis s'il n'est
pas escorté
[Musique]
mais cette faiblesse matérielle est
largement compensée par une maîtrise
stratégique et tactique exceptionnelle
qui met les généros Allemands au-dessus
de leurs homologues européens
l'invasion de la Pologne le premier
septembre 1939 qui détermine le 3
l'entrée de la France et de l'Angleterre
dans la guerre a été un véritable coup
de poker le flanc gauche de la Wehrmacht
est en effet pratiquement à découvert et
une vigoureuse attaque de l'armée
française d'ailleurs redoutée par les
généraux allemands pourraient facilement
renverser la situation
seul la quatrième armée du général
requin marche vers la ligne Siegfried sa
progression est stoppée par l'état-major
le 12 septembre
à l'autre bout du front les Panzer ont
rapidement raison de la résistance des
Polonais brave mais mal commandé malarmé
et malentraîné les vagues de Bombardier
de chasseurs détruisent les villes les
villages les routes les terrains
d'aviation et les usines en quatre
semaines le pays est à genoux les
Allemands ont capturé 649 000
prisonniers et non perdu que 8000 hommes
les soldats qui défilent d'en Varsovie
conquises ont mérité leur croix de fer
mais leur chef savent qu'il faut
profiter de la victoire on sait
qu'Hitler envisage de lancer très vite
son plan jaune l'invasion de la France
la date on ne la connaît pas mais elle
se situe peut-être dans quelques
semaines
non seulement les troupes les tremblins
et les matériels ne sont pas encore
prêts mais le temps n'est pas favorable
la météo contre un Hitler à reporter
sans cesse l'attaque le Führer reçoit
régulièrement ses généraux au Berghoff
comme ici dittel le célèbre chef des
troupes de montagne qui ont combattu
français anglais à Narvik
tout en discutant avec le Führer dans la
grande salle panoramique du Berghoff dit
elle se doute que les Alliés risquent de
mettre à profit le délai que leur laisse
Hitler et de prendre l'initiative
la stratégie de la Wehrmacht est tout
entière contenue dans ce fameux plan
jaune conçu par le général fonmanstein
qui préconise le passage en force à
travers les Ardennes suivi du coup de
fou consistant à se rabattre d'un seul
coup vers l'ouest en refoulant français
belge et britannique vers la mer afin de
les années en tir
la réussite de ce plan audacieux
reposait essentiellement sur la rapidité
de son exécution sur la surprise aussi
car aucun général français ne s'attend à
une attaque par le massif forestier des
Ardennes réputé un franchissable pour
les unités blindées
Manstein et gout derrière le célèbre
théoricien dépend des heures pense et
vont prouver le contraire
le plan débute par un assaut puissant
mais conventionnel sur les Pays-Bas
incluant notamment les parachutistes et
les forces aériennes de Goering qui se
donnent un rôle essentiel auprès de
Hitler au sol les chars font sont à
travers la forêt avant de se rabattre
vers la mer
dans l'esprit du chef de la wehrmarque
les lignes alliés seront alors trop
allongées pour résister et elle se
désintégreront sous les coups de boutoir
des divisions blindées
il s'agit d'une stratégie très risquée
pour un homme qui est surtout un leader
politique a priori plus à l'aise au
congrès de Nuremberg devant les SAS et
les SS que dans un rôle de chef
militaire en fait il compte sur la
faiblesse de ses adversaires
or sur ce plan il n'a pas tort l'armée
française qui a vaincu l'Allemagne en
1918 vit sur une réputation qui n'est
plus à la hauteur de la réalité forte en
nombre et les commander par des chefs
âgés dans la doctrine est basée sur la
défense à outrance et l'immobilisme
l'une et l'autre symbolisée par la
fameuse ligne Maginot fortifications
modernes mais construite à l'économie et
qui peut être tournée sur la droite
comme sur la gauche
le corps des officiers de carrière
comprend d'excellents éléments mais
l'initiative y est mal vu y compris aux
échelons supérieurs ainsi les vu
novatrices d'un colonel de Gaulle
partisan acharné des chars et que l'on
voit ici présenter son régiment au
président Albert Lebrun sont considérés
comme révolutionnaires et à ce titre
négligé même après que la campagne de
Pologne est prouvée la justesse de ces
thèses on considère en haut lieu qu'une
guerre éclair est impensable vis-à-vis
de la France cela n'empêche pas les
usines d'armement de produire les chars
qui vont se battre pendant la campagne
de France
les affiches de la mobilisation générale
apparaissent dans une atmosphère de
défiance vis-à-vis d'un gouvernement
déconsidéré
pour beaucoup d'ouvriers cette guerre
est avant tout une guerre capitaliste
ainsi que le répète les messages de
propagande allemande par-dessus le rein
quant aux classes plus favorisées elles
ont tendance à reprocher à l'Angleterre
d'entraîner la France dans un conflit
sans issue enfin les souvenirs de la
Première Guerre mondiale prédisposent
mal civils et militaires aux
perspectives d'un nouveau conflit
mai 1940 l'Allemagne est prête avions et
Panzer sortent par milliers de ses
usines au moment même où la Wehrmacht
s'apprête à attaquer le gouvernement de
Paul Reynaud tombe
certains que leurs adversaires ne
s'aventureront pas au-delà de la ligne
Maginot les Allemands n'ont laissé
devant elle qu'un mince cordon de trous
les 29 divisions du groupe d'armée B de
funbox et les 45 du groupe A de
funhunstett son massés pour jouer
respectivement le rôle d'enclume et de
marteau
les 2475 chars français on ne sait pas
assez sont plus nombreux et plus
modernes que les 1728 Panzer équipant
les 6 Panzer Division
le char sommea et de loin le meilleur
mieux armé mieux blindé que le Panzer 3
dans sa tourelle le chef de char peut
tout seul diriger donner ses ordres
armés et tirés alors que pour les mêmes
tâches les panzers nécessitent un
équipage
sur les 108 divisions de l'armée
française deux seulement son motorisés
et aucune n'est blindée les chars ne
sont considérés par le commandement que
comme des armes d'appoint ils doivent
être répartis dans les grandes unités et
non regroupées en formation manoeuvre
les chats
renaudas tout comme les armes
entièresiennes et les cheniettes sont
fabriqués en grand nombre mais ils sont
aussi exportés et manqueront au moment
où il le faudra
du côté allemand comme et pas de telles
erreurs ainsi le canon flaque de 88 mm
l'un des canons anti-aériens les plus
efficaces de la guerre s'est révélé en
Espagne une arme formidable contre les
chars
les 1300 avions de l'armée de l'air
française sont par contre surclassés par
une Luftwaffe plus nombreuse et plus
moderne mais c'est encore au niveau de
ses chefs que l'armée française pêche le
plus le généralisme Maurice Gamelin et
brillant mais puis ilanime c'est un
politique plus qu'un militaire il
s'entend mal avec son second le général
Georges réaliste mais trop discipliné
pour contester des décisions qu'il la
prouvent cependant pas
toute la stratégie française ne repose
décidément que sur la ligne Maginot dans
les 465 km longe d'une partie de la
frontière et s'arrête près du Luxembourg
22.000 hommes des troupes de forteresse
tiennent les 40 gros ouvrages les 70
petits les 415m et les 150 km de galerie
souterraine de la ligne
hérissée de tourelle et de canon lourd
au-delà de cette ligne fortifiée qu'il
est apparemment facile de contourner on
trouve l'obstacle naturel des Ardennes
et la ville de Sedan précédent
immédiatement la Belgique
s'attendant à une attaque à travers ce
pays neutre Gamelin a prévu un mouvement
de ces troupes vers le nord en direction
de la rivière d'Ille
Gamelin compte aussi sur le corps
expéditionnaire anglais la BF British
expéditionary force commandé par l'ordre
si les soldats britanniques sont tous
des professionnels aguerris et
disciplinés ils ne sont pas assez
nombreux la BEF compte à peine 11
divisions sa dotation blindée nettement
insuffisante et surtout composée de
chars légers marxis largement périmé les
chars modernes Mathilda étant très peu
nombreux quant à l'artillerie elle ne
peut faire face sérieusement aux canons
allemands
tout comme la France la Grande-Bretagne
est en effet entrée en guerre sans
préparation militaire sa petite armée
est en grande partie composée d'hommes
peu motivés et d'anciens chômeurs
le corps des sous-officiers des
officiers manquent d'émulation les
promotions étant rare et ne favorisant
pas l'esprit d'initiative
cette mentalité est à l'opposé de cette
mise en œuvre par le Troisième Reich qui
encourage l'esprit militariste des
hommes dès leur adolescence
seul la Royale Navy arme traditionnelle
de l'Angleterre mais aussi la Royal Air
Force font l'objet de l'attention du
haut commandement britannique le
bombardement stratégique est largement
prôné dans les états majeurs pourtant
les bombardiers sont pour la plupart
lents et vulnérables par contre les
chasseurs notamment les eurêkaïnes et
les Spitfire sont très performants ils
vont bientôt le prouver
les hommes politiques britanniques le
Premier ministre Chamberlin en tête sont
largement opposés à tout risque de
guerre pendant de longs mois le cabinet
soutenu par le Parlement va témoigner
ces déduit terrain devant Hitler
le pape anglais lui accepte de moins en
moins cette faiblesse politique
insensiblement il entre dans la guerre
non seulement avec le départ des soldats
vers un front pour l'instant limité à
celui que tient la BF en France dans la
région d'Arras mais en prenant toutes
les mesures permettant d'éloigner les
enfants des grandes villes
le 10 mai 1940 jour de l'attaque
allemande le pusillanime Chamberlain est
remplacé par un homme à poigne Winston
Churchill
ce jour-là à l'aube l'avait remarque
attaque simultanément en Hollande en
Belgique et au Luxembourg les
parachutistes du général Studen sautant
des Juncker 52 prennent les ponts de
Rotterdam de dordretsch et de murdjik
la sixième armée du général von reichnod
s'avance à l'extrême droite de la
Belgique le long de la Meuse et du canal
Albert
les parachutistes jouent un rôle
essentiel dans la réussite de cette
attaque surprise c'est essentiellement
leur action que deux jours plus tard
sera dû la reddition de la Hollande
les blancs des Allemands font à travers
les plaines vides de relief qui
s'étendent entre la mer du Nord et la
Moselle et franchissent sans coup férir
flaves et rivières
à 6h30 le 10 mai Gamelin ordonne le
déclenchement de la manœuvre d'îles le
corps de cavalerie français la première
armée plusieurs divisions et brigades
des 2e et 9e armée entre en Belgique au
nord de Namur le 11 mai le détachement
aéroporté du capitaine Koch chez les
éléments du génie s'empare du fort
d'Eben et Maëlle position clé qui domine
le canal Albert l'armée belge commence à
reculer
abandonnons leur position d'attente les
troupes françaises du général Biot et
les Anglais de la BEF se portent au
secours de leurs alliés belges ce n'est
pas là cependant mais sur la Meuse que
tout va se jouer
le groupement blindé de funcliste font à
travers les Ardennes réputées
infranchissables et les traversent en
difficulté majeures
les longues colonnes parfaitement
organisées et dirigées obligent ainsi
les divisions de cavalerie française à
repasser sur la rive gauche de la Meuse
le 12 mai en fin d'après-midi la
septième Panzer du général romelle
arrive devant Dinan
ses premiers éléments passent la Meuse
dans la nuit et l'infanterie la franchit
le lendemain le même jour les
avant-gardes de gouderian n'en font
autant dans le secteur de Sedan et crée
une tête de pont à la marée les
Allemands sont en France
dans la nuit du 13 au 14 les panzers
commencent le franchissement sur des
ponts de bateaux malgré l'aviation
française et anglaise les Allemands
engagent alors un bombardement de 6
heures sur Sedan et malgré une farouche
résistance réduisent les Français au
silence
au nord de Sedan il ne reste plus que la
neuvième armée du général korap elle est
composée de troupes mal entraînés de
réservistes âgés qui quelques semaines
auparavant étaient encore dans leur
ferme elles ne dispose pas de matériel
moderne et d'armement adéquates et
encore moins d'artillerie sous l'attaque
des chtoucas corps est menacée
d'enveloppement sont front et crevés au
nord ils ne dispose d'aucun soutien et
finit par donner l'ordre de repli et
découvre ainsi la première armée qui
doit retraitée à son tour
une large brèche existe maintenant entre
Dinant et Sedan les divisions blindées
allemandes suivant les avant-gardes si
engouffre à partir du 15 mai
illustre parfaitement l'affrontement de
deux conceptions opposées de la guerre
pour les Français les Anglais celles-ci
doit être menées au rythme de
l'infanterie c'est-à-dire lentement pour
les Allemands au contraire la vitesse
conditionne tout
c'est pourquoi non seulement les blindés
sont privilégiés dans la stratégie du
haut commandement mais encore ils
emportent leur propre carburant ce qui
les rend indépendants
ils sont en outre équipés de radio
permettant aux commandants de
détachement de communiquer à tout
instant avec leur chef de char
au contraire les cadres des blindés
françaises et britanniques ne peuvent
utiliser qu'un réseau téléphonique très
endommagé par la guerre et des
estafettes soumises à tous les risques
la pratique du commandement diffère
également les Allemands pratiquent une
large de légation et communiquent très
vite leurs adversaires étant obligé
d'attendre la confirmation des ordres
reçus parfois d'une très longue distance
et par des moyens peu sûr tout cela sur
un champ de bataille sillonné par
d’interminables colonnes de réfugiés
gênant les mouvements
ces réfugiés sont souvent aussi les
cibles des stocks aviation d'assaut
allemandes dont la mission première est
de détruire les routes les voies ferrées
les ponts les nœuds de communication les
dépôts des sens les gares et les
aérodromes accompagnés
de la BF sont partiellement engagés
auprès des unités françaises dans le
secteur limité par Louvain et la Wavre
le 14 mai les bombardiers de la Royal
Air Force appuyaient par des appareils
français tentent de détruire les ponts
de Sedan intactes et qu'empruntent les
chars de gouderianes mais la flaque les
attend et là-bas 85 apparaît donc 46
appartenant aux unités avancées de la
RAF stationné en France
le maréchal de l'herbe Downing chef de
la chasse britannique juge alors que ses
forces ne peuvent rester exposées en
France car il est certain que
l'Angleterre va être attaqué sous peu il
s'oppose donc désormais à tout transfert
d'escadrille vers le continent l'armée
de l'air va donc continuer à se battre
seul héroïquement malgré sa faiblesse
face à la louve vaffeux
la bataille désert est très rude les
Allemands de lave même quand fera plus
tard le célèbre général Adolphe Galande
il perdent de nombreux appareils l'AST
Mulders lui-même est abattu mais
l'hécatombe d'appareils français
britanniques et terrible
la progression des divisions allemandes
est très rapide les divisions motorisées
elles-mêmes ont du mal à les suivre
la retraite désormais françaises belges
et britanniques et totale malgré des
faits d'armes incontestables la défense
de mon Hermé le 13 mai la bataille de
chars de Gembloux le 14 celle de Stone
et de Rethel le 15
ce même 15 mai la Hollande capitule
on s'attend à ce que l'armée allemande
font sur Paris il n'en est rien
exécutant à la lettre le fameux coup de
fou préconisé par le général fun les
Panzer de gouderian roulent à toute
vitesse vers la mer à l'ouest
ils font sans traversant les champs de
bataille de l'autre guerre réveillant
des souvenirs chez les combattants
allemands qu'il y avait participé
au dessus des colonnes blindées les
jetons sur les routes encombrées d'unité
française en retraite et de réfugiés
fuyant par dizaines de milliers les
zones envahies le bruit court que des
agents de la 5ème colonne facilitent
l'avance des Allemands et la gendarmerie
française arrête de nombreux suspects en
fusil même quelques-uns
pendant que les réfugiés courbent le dos
sous les bombes la retraite française
sur Lescaut se poursuit devant la
sixième armée allemande
le groupe d'armée a le groupement du
général hot et le 19e corps blindé
s'ouvre un passage de 100 km vers
l'ouest
dès le 17 mai le cabinet britannique
soucieux de ménager son corps
expéditionnelle envisage secrètement son
réembarquement le 19 au moment même où
il envisageait une contre-attaque
Gamelin est remplacé par le général
végan appelé d'urgence de Syrie les
Allemands avançant inexorablement font
prisonniers de nombreux anglais
le 18 mai le maréchal Pétain ambassadeur
en Espagne a été rappelé d'urgence et
nommé vice-président du conseil il est
convaincu de l'inéluctabilité de la
défaite et en rejette la responsabilité
immédiate sur les angles qui en franco
il lui confie mon pays est battu je
retourne à Angers la paix les
prisonniers français se comptent par
milliers et pourtant au milieu de
l'atmosphère défaitiste des troupes se
battent encore et de jeunes officiers
appellent à grands cris la
contre-attaque telle ceux de l'école de
cavalerie de Saumur qui vont bientôt
commander leurs élèves sur la Loire
le général de Gaulle lance sa quatrième
DCR en cours de formation sur le flanc
des Allemands entre Montcornet et Crécy
une attaque audacieuse mais sans
lendemain
malgré leur succès les Allemands eux
aussi rencontrent des difficultés Hitler
et plusieurs membres de son état-major
presque effrayé par cette victoire trop
facile et inquiet d'une éventuelle
réplique franco-britannique arrête par
deux fois gouderiane qui fonce en tête
du 19e corps blindé le 20 mai enfin
malgré les routes encombrées ces
panzerataï Abbeville et la mer créant
deux têtes de pont au sud de la Somme
puis il se dirige sur Boulogne et Calais
au même moment végan veut lancer une
contre-attaque franco-britannique
d'Arras sur Bapaume ce plan oblige
l'armée belge un nouveau repli vers
l'Isère afin de couvrir cette action
mais les mauvaises liaisons les
embouteillages et le désordre dû à
l'action de la Luftwaffe empêche de
coordonner les mouvements pour les
Anglais Dunkerque devient de plus en
plus un objectif prioritaire
Churchill fait de fréquents passages en
France au cours de l'un d'entre eux le
20 mai il donne l'ordre à l'orgore de
lancer une contre-attaque au sud d'Arras
les Allemands continuent à s'infiltrer
négligeant tous les obstacles
les soldats du corps expéditionnaire
britannique vont prouver de quoi ils
sont encore capables
le 21 de division incomplète soutenu par
des chars Matilda mais sans couverture
aérienne sérieuse inflige des pertes
sensibles à la septième Panzer de
remelle qui croit se trouver devant 5
divisions mais le 19e corps blindé
allemand reprend rapidement l'offensif
sur Boulogne et menace le BEF dans
cerclement Total
les troubles indés françaises continuent
à se battre dans une lutine égale de
nombreux équipages tombent entre les
mains de l'adversaire
doit se concerter le 21 avec végan à
Ypres mais retardé par les combats il
arrive trop tard de ce rendez-vous
manqué résultats une méfiance réciproque
entre les deux chefs
et pourtant grâce à l'initiative de
Churchill des troupes britanniques
arrivent encore en France ce sont les
dernières les avant-gardes allemandes
approchent de Dunkerque
au large les vaisseaux de guerre anglais
tirent maintenant directement sur les
Allemands visibles sur les côtes les
soldats du BEF marchent aussi vite que
possible verdunkerque d'où l'ordre il ne
s'en cache plus vote évacuer son corps
expéditionnaire vers l'Angleterre dans
cette course les Anglais vont être
sauvés par un coup du sort
en effet le 24 mai alors que la première
Panzer Division du général von runstett
vient de conquérir une tête de pont sur
la à quelques kilomètres de Dunkerque
Hitler lui donne l'ordre de stopper son
avance sur place le même ordre est
envoyé au 41e corde armée cette décision
l'une des plus controversées de la
guerre a été prise pour laisser à la
luftwaf de going le soin de détruire
seul les armées encerclées
la ville commence à subir un
bombardement en règle de leur chars les
tankistes allemands observent
rageusement à la jumelle la ville qui
leur échappe on a beaucoup discuté sur
les motifs de ce coup d'arrêt on a
avancé les problèmes de liaison des
Allemands la lenteur des
approvisionnements en carburant
il reste certain qui clairs
lui qui voulait voir ses troupes d'élite
les SS vers fourgon stroopen se couvrir
de gloire mais il cède à son favori
going qui bout d'un patience et entend
donner la première place à sa loft WAF
et celle-ci attaque en effet avec les
chasseurs Messerschmidt et phoque et
Wolf et les bombardiers légers Juncker
88 mais elle n'obtiendra aucun résultat
tangible le 26 mai l'ordre sera annulé
il sera trop tard
la poche de défense organisée de le 20
mai par l'ordre autour de Dunkerque et
basé sur une ligne de résistance
utilisant les canaux reliant les
rivières importantes l'Escaut la Scarpe
la Deule
le camp retranché est défendu à l'ouest
par les Français de la 68e division
d'infanterie et au sud par des éléments
des premiers et deuxième corps d'armée
britannique le 26 mai Lord reçoit
l'ordre formel de commencer l'Opération
Dynamo on ne pensait pas pouvoir sauver
plus de 50 000 hommes sur les 200000
Anglais Français déjà regroupés sur les
plages depuis le 17 près de 30 000
hommes des services arrières avaient été
embarqués à Boulogne
près de 800 bateaux anglais de toutes
sortes vont participer à l'opération en
Angleterre l'opinion publique et mal
informé et les soldats qui vont échapper
à l'enfer de Dunkerque vont se rendre
compte à quel point les informations de
la radio et de la presse sont
incomplètes
en arrière de la poche les combats se
poursuivent les Allemands ne rencontrent
aucune résistance de venteuses sinon au
cours de combat sporadique n'engageant
que des effectifs limités
le port les docks et la ville
disparaissent sous des péages de fumée
due au bombardement qui pilonnent
Dunkerque depuis 10 jours
le 27 les vagues de 30 à 40 bombardiers
se succèdent de 7 heures du matin à 7h
du soir elle coule plusieurs navires
dans le port ou aux abords de celui-ci
le commandement de l'Opération Dynamo a
été confiée aux vices amiral Ramsay
commandant à Douvres
c'est de là que partent les 40 destroyer
et les 120 bateaux de passagers et de
pêche en direction de la côte française
l'opération commence mal les bateaux ne
peuvent accéder qu'au port extérieur et
seulement à marée haute une fois à
proximité des côtes ils sont pris sous
le feu des batteries allemandes les
hommes s'accumulent sur les plages
encombrées le premier jour seul 7600
d'entre eux peuvent être évacués
le lendemain matin les commandants
alliés dont le capitaine de vaisseau
offens chef des opérations à la miroute
et française se réunissent à Cassel il
décide de consolider la tête de pont
les troupes anglaises et françaises
continuent d'affluer en bon ordre mais
de moins en moins discipliné les
fantassins du général beau-frère et des
éléments du secteur fortifié des
Flandres assure la plus grande partie de
la défense ils
ignorent encore que les Anglais des
premiers et deuxième corps qui les a pu
au sud ont reçu l'ordre de se retirer
progressivement
sur les plages les Anglais commencent à
détruire matériel armes véhicules et
équipements les leurs mais aussi parfois
se défoncer
des ordres mal compris entraînent même
la mise hors d'usage de précieux canon
de DCA pendant ce temps la loft va feu
poursuit le bombardement de la ville
pratiquement détruite près de 1000
civils ils sont tués le même jour
la Royal Air Force ne se manifeste
pratiquement pas
seuls quelques Squadron survolent de
temps à autre le champ de bataille il ne
reste pas longtemps dans Ding leur a
donné l'ordre de nataquer les Allemands
qu'avant leur arrivée sur la tête de
pont et au moment de leur départ mais
cela les soldats sur la plage ne le
savent pas et la colère grande
de nombreux bateaux coulent touchés par
les bombes à terre les dépôts des sens
du port brulent aussi dégageant des Pen
nuages de fumée les pilotes de Henkel
111 abusé par ces nuages sont persuadés
d'avoir entièrement anéanti les
installations portuaires et tout ce qui
s'y trouvaient
c'est à ce moment qu'une période de très
mauvais temps donne aux aciers et aux
fugitifs un RIP inespéré
de Douvres le vice amiral Ramsay dirige
les opérations d'évacuation coordonnées
sur place par ses officiers de liaison
sous les ordres du Captain tenant
constatant que le port lui-même est
difficilement utilisable celui-ci décide
d'embarquer les hommes à partir des
plages bien que celle-ci soit
fréquemment prise sous le feu des
bombardiers en piqué
le tyrando ne permet pas au bateau
d'approcher suffisamment du rivage les
troupes embarquent sur des canaux et des
barques et s'approche lentement des gros
navires en évitant les courants et les
projectiles
une fois à bord les soldats respirent un
peu leurs camarades restaient à terre
attendent stoïquement leur tour rassurés
en partie par cette flotte d'évacuation
qui même été reclite restent imposante
si les nerfs la discipline revient s'il
le faut sous la menace des armes des
officiers
les Français sont évacués au même titre
que les Britanniques et leur foule
quoique moins nombreuses encombrent les
ponts des bateaux surchargés faute de
radio les liaisons entre la flotte et la
plage utilisent uniquement le morse des
sémaphores
dès le second jour 12000 hommes sont
évacués par le port et 6000 par les
plages mais Ramsay trouve que les choses
vont trop lentement certaines
embarcations sont pleines à rabord
d'autres presque vides on découvre deux
moules qui avancent loin dans la mer de
chaque côté du port
ces deux constructions en bois ont
surtout pour vocation de servir de brise
l'âme et ne sont pas faites pour que des
bateaux yakost la mère passe entre les
piles et les vagues y déferlent de
plusieurs mètres pour les pilotes des
navires et les marins ces moules
deviennent rapidement un cauchemar et
pourtant le 27 mai au soir 200000 hommes
ont réussi à embarquer en partant de cet
endroit dangereux entre tous
le lendemain 28 mai l'armée belge
capitule ainsi tombe le dernier rempart
devant la 17e armée allemande végan
donne l'ordre général Blanchard son chef
de sofrayer un chemin par la force vers
la côte
à Dunkerque si la loft va feu est clouée
au sol par le mauvais temps les canons
prennent le relais et bombardent la
flotte en y créant des ravages
les bateaux arrivent toujours devant les
plages il y en a vraiment de toutes
sortes et des plus étranges comme ceci
l'évacuation se poursuit cependant dans
la seule journée du 31 mai ont réussi à
embarquer 68000 hommes mais le danger
est toujours là si la flotte de haute
mer allemande est trop loin en Norvège
les vedettes rapides de la crix marine
appuyées par les escadrilles de
chasseurs fonce verdunkerque
les chtoucas surtout attaquent à nouveau
sans relâche en voyant de nombreux
bateaux par le fond avec leur chargement
humain qui ne peut souvent qu’être
partiellement sauvé
le 29 mai 4 destroyer sont coulés en
pleine opération d'évacuation le bruit
court que leurs épaves bloquent le port
il était René mais inquiète la mirauté
qui rappelle ses unités les plus
modernes afin de ne pas les exposer ne
laissant à Ramsès qu'une quinzaine de
vieux modèles deux précieux jours
passent avant que l'erreur ne soit
rectifiée
à Dunkerque l'atmosphère est lourde les
Anglais continuent à embarquer en grand
nombre grâce aux prodigieux efforts de
la Royale Navy et à la protection
assurée par les troupes françaises
encouragés par leur chef l'amiral Abrial
et le contre-amiral Platon nommé
gouverneur de la ville en pleine
bataille
les derniers défenseurs britanniques
sont bientôt relevés par deux divisions
françaises commandées par le général de
la Laurent si qui refusant de se laisser
évacuer combattra jusqu'au 3 juin
à la fin du mois Churchill à l'armée par
la différence entre le nombre de
Britanniques et de français évacuées
demande au Conseil de guerre à lire et
réunis à Paris que les soldats des
donations quittent Dunkerque la main
dans l'âme pour faire face aux Allemands
qui assiègent le corps tranché il
remplace Lord par le Major Général
Alexander
jusqu'à lors et bien que de nombreux
marins civils se soient portés
volontaires l'Opération Dynamo a été
entièrement exécutée par la Royale Navy
elle est même cachée au peuple anglais
le 31 mai les informations de la BBC
sont presque entièrement consacrés aux
émeutes anti-allemandes de beyne-hozère
cependant le lendemain à 18h le peuple
britannique commence à soupçonner
quelque chose
le premier juin une incroyable armada de
petits bateaux entame résolument la
traversée de la Manche durant deux jours
ils vont faire la navette avec la côte
française emmenant les soldats jusqu'au
grand navire ou ramassant les traînards
tout cela sous le tir des allemands
installés sur les hauteurs de marque
ces amateurs font preuve d'un
extraordinaire courage s'il sauve peu
d'hommes en comparaison de la masse
totale des évacués la légende sans par
cependant de leur épopée et avec raison
les plages et les bords de mer de
Dunkerque sont envahis de matériel de
véhicule et d'armes abandonnées
les troupes qui restent en arrière pour
retarder l'avancement sont épuisés mais
les soldats du troisième âge bien que
victorieux sont aussi fortement éprouvés
ils sont à court d’eau de vivre et de
munitions il manque d'artillerie les
batteries les plus puissantes ayant été
envoyées sur d'autres zones du front
seuls les escadrilles de la loft va feu
sont en nombre les messages Schmidt 109
décollent et attaquent sans répit les
Français ne gardent que 300 avions en
état de marche 700 autres ont été
détruits
la Royal Air Force n'envoie que huit
patrouilles vers les plages les pilotes
de Göring eux ayant décollé tôt le matin
coule 3 destroyer et 3 autres poses
devant le rivage sévèrement endommagé
Ramsay donne alors l'ordre d'interrompre
les navigations de jour à minuit 65000
hommes ont cependant été évacués le
lendemain ce chiffre tombe à 26000
malgré cela les Anglais peuvent envoyer
le message suivant corps expéditionnaire
britannique évacué
les Français ont la désagréable
impression que les Britanniques
négligent de les évacuer malgré les
promesses il est vrai que si les soldats
anglais sont prioritaires ils sont aussi
les plus nombreux mais la myrotech
Britannique parvient à embarquer un
grand nombre de soldats français 50 000
les premiers de jeux on y voit toutes
les armes tous les grades mais les
visages haras cette fatigue sont les
mêmes
le 4 juin dernier jour de dynamo 342 618
soldats liés ont été évacués moins de
40000 hommes restent aux mains de
l'ennemi sur le total d'environ 400 000
que la Persée allemande avait isolé au
nord de la ligne Sedan Abbeville ce
jour-là les Allemands entrent dans la
ville ils vont y rester 5 ans
l'armée française compte encore à cette
date un million et demi d'hommes capable
de continuer le combat
même si des centaines de milliers de
prisonniers marchent sur la route de la
captivité
les Allemands de leur côté ont
complètement redéployé leur dispositif
au 139 divisions allemandes le général
végan va en opposer 71 moitié moins
le 5 juin Hitler lancé Panzer et son
infanterie sur la Somme et les lettres
les combats font rage pendant deux jours
le 6 le général touche on ramène sa
sixième armée sur l'aine et le général
allemand hot franchit la scène le 9
remède et sa septième Panzer arrive à
leur tour sur la scène
au nord malgré les succès passagers des
généraux au blé et Delattre sur
l'Argonne et à Rethel les Allemands
dotés d'une impressionnante artillerie
crée une tête de pont l'armée française
abandonne laine et se replient en
Champagne les obus pilonnent la ligne
Maginot encerclés menacés par gouderiane
mais encore tenu par le deuxième groupe
d'armée
à Paris le gouvernement montre son
affolement le général végan est
parfaitement conscient que la partie est
jouée le 10 juin alors que les troupes
allemandes se répandent sur toutes les
routes franchissent toutes les rivières
Paris est évacué le gouvernement se
transporte à Bordeaux le 13 au Conseil
des ministres végan se prononce pour la
cessation des hostilités
les prisonniers les fuyards et les
réfugiés encombrent tous les grands axes
descendants vers le sud
le 23 juin 1940 au petit matin Hitler
arrive seul à Paris pour visiter la
ville lumière il est accompagné d'un
petit groupe parmi lesquels l'architecte
Albert spare et le sculpteur Arnaud
Brecker la capitale est déserte
trois jours auparavant Mussolini qui
était resté jusqu'ici dans une prudent
très réserve a déclaré à son tour la
guerre à la France et attaquée dans les
Alpes malgré les randomontades du Dolce
l'armée italienne va se heurter aux
troupes de montagne et de forteresse
aguerris commandé par le général hollery
avec ces trois divisions de série B
celui-ci va contenir brillamment son
adversaire et seule l'arrivée des
troubles l'un des Allemands du général
Hepner l'obligera à cesser le combat
malgré ses succès
les Français parisiens et provinciaux
voient entre le vainqueur dans la
capitale et dans de nombreuses villes au
nord de la Loire
à Bordeaux Paul Reynaud président du
Conseil tente de convaincre ses
collègues de passer en Afrique du Nord
pour continuer la lutte
[Musique]
Reno est remplacé par le maréchal Pétain
qui entre en contact avec les Allemands
le vainqueur de Verdun rencontrera
Hitler à Montoire quelques semaines plus
tard
[Musique]
à Londres où il est retourné à la suite
d'une mission officielle confiée par le
gouvernement le Général de Gaulle a créé
la France libre et lancé son célèbre
appel du 18 juin qu'en vérité peu de
Français entendent
si l'armée française est vaincue la
flotte elle demeur intacte elle va
devenir un enjeu essentiel notamment
pour l'Angleterre qui redoute de l'avoir
tombé entre les mains des allemands la
Royale comme on l'appelle va être au
centre de nombreuses discussions
le 21 juin Hitler convoque la délégation
française d'armistice à Rethondes où le
11 novembre 1918 l'Empire allemand avait
lui-même capitulé devant le maréchal
Foch dans la clairière historique le
célèbre wagon restaurant est toujours là
c'est là aussi que le Führer du
Troisième Reich a tenu à savourer sa
victoire entouré des grands chefs de
l'armée de la louve va feu et de la
crique se marine il y a tant les
plénipotentiaires emmenés par le général
huntinger et l'ambassadeur Léon Noël
c'est après quitte les rira contemplé
Paris du haut du Trocadéro la France est
coupée en deux par la ligne de
démarcation
au rêve du dictateur succèdent les
troupes allemandes qui défilent sur la
Place de l'Étoile et descend de l'avenue
du bois aujourd'hui avenue Foch
le retour en Allemagne est un triomphe
la foule acclame sans relâche le chef du
Troisième Reich la honte du traité de
Versailles était passée pour le peuple
allemande jamais plus Hitler ne
connaîtra un tel enthousiasme
aux acclamations de la foule succèdent
les applaudissements du Reichstag mais
pour Hitler la guerre n'est pas achevée
il explique à ses généraux groupés
autour des cartes qu'après la victoire
sur l'Angleterre qui pour lui ne fait
aucun doute il faudra encore aller plus
loin mais cette fois-ci vers l'est
c'est à quoi déjà il entend préparé ses
troupes il dispose déjà de corps d'élite
telle cette fameuse BAFA ne cesse dont
les blindés défilent ici à Paris devant
leur chef cette Dietrich et
l'aubergroupen Führer
du Feld du maréchal von stead
l'année à venir va être entièrement
occupée par la préparation de ce qui
sera l'opération Barbaros
[Musique]
à Londres de Gaulle et départ Churchill
constitue le noyau des Forces Françaises
Libres composées surtout au début de
marins et de soldats évacués de
Dunkerque
[Musique]
la population britannique entre
réellement dans la spirale de la guerre
la bataille d’angleterre a commencé dès
le lendemain de l'Opération Dynamo
speedfire et Eury Kane entame ce combat
historique contre la Luftwaffe dont les
chasseurs et les bombardiers ont pour
mission d'anéantir la résistance
anglaise cette bataille va durer
jusqu'en octobre 1940 et s'achèvera par
la défaite allemande
[Musique]
aux attaques des chasseurs s'ajouteront
très vite les bombardements
systématiques de Londres et des grandes
villes c'est le Blitz qui fera des
milliers de victimes civiles
les Anglais qui avaient appris par la
radio ce qui se passait à Rotterdam à
Sedan ou à Varsovie découvre à leur tour
les horreurs des villes en feu ils
savent désormais pourquoi ils se battent
et ils vont le faire avec un cran
admirable
un cran que ça lui RA Churchill lui-même
dans un discours devant le cabinet de
guerre
discours diffusé au peuple britannique
qui s'y reconnaîtra tout entier
[Musique]